for this judge the determinant factors  for the sentencing seem to mainly be  that they step forward and mid guilt and  take responsibility but also that they  not have involved their child and he  didn't it's undisputed from the  government that Gordon Kaplan's daughter  had nothing to do with this did not was  not aware of this that her dad had done  this and I think that is important and  mr. Caplan talked about that actually  that this was all about his own  ambitions for his child how it reflected  on him not necessarily what was best for  her it's been a difficult six months for  warden Kaplan this case has been the  focus of his life in many ways he's done  a lot of volunteer work to fill hours as  well and but he's done a lot of  reflecting a lot of thinking and my  advice to Gordon was speak from the  heart to the judge and he did